yeah okay well he he activated his king  and  levon has moved his rook that was under  fire  and still the big threat in the position  is for the white king  to come forward and black's pieces  will just work together as a team  just to coordinate deadly threats  against black's kings there's just  nothing that  magnus can do barring a huge blunder by  lavonne  yep but he's not showing any inclination  right now to blunder or make any mistake  it's been  a show a display of pure accuracy by  levan aronian it's been so consistent as  well he built up this pawn center  what was it 30 moves ago and uh it still  remains to this day and magnus carson  just resigns  he gives up in a hopeless position  against iranian wow horrible start to  the semi-finals for world champion  magnus carlson losing game one  to the fantastic levon ronian who is  definitely  keeping his calm here no smile on  levonaronian's face but a great start